wir gucken auf dem nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt dem ganzen liegt
zugrunde ein entschließungsantrag der
aus der fdp-fraktion kommt es geht um
die sicherung der grenzen europäischer
als auch deutscher und der erste redner
ist gottfried curio sehr geehrter
präsidentin die augen in den sinn
plötzlich bringen die bilder von der
türkischen grenze das problem wieder ins
bewusstsein
die permanente illegale migration die
verweigerung des grenzschutzes wir
erinnern uns alle
die europäische grenzen verletzten
kommen vorher über sichere drittstaaten
sind beim grenzübertritt ohne anspruch
auf schutz ausnahme an aufnahme und
schon in irak in afghanistan gibt flucht
alternativen unter krieg in syrien wo
ein erdogan ihn nicht befeuert ist
längst weitgehend aus 2017 sagte der
türkische aussenminister heilige kriege
werden bald in europa beginnen und
erdogan zur eu wenn ihr euch weiter so
benimmt wird morgen kein einziger
europäer irgendwo auf der welt sicher
einen schritt auf die straße setzen
können jetzt sammeln sie sich aus idlib
dem letzten widerstandsnester der
islamistischen aggression und migranten
die schon lange in der türkei leben und
sich dort versorgen
alle wollen sich absetzen ins gelobte
land in sozial paradies europa ins
schlaraffenland deutschland vor ort
befragt erzählen sie ihr ziel ist
schlicht hier besser zu leben
fluchtursachen bekämpfen die flucht
ursache heißt deutschland opulentes
sozialsystem bei lachsen asyl
bedingungen und wer will wieder am
besten alle reinholen die grünen mit
denen die union demnächst dieses land
lenken will schwarz grün das wort
gruselkabinett bekommt er eine ganz neue
bedeutung
nur da wo jetzt die migrationsbewegung
wieder optisch sichtbar wird da gibt man
sich mal zugeknöpft vor einer
bayerischen kommunalwahl aber
gleichzeitig schreibt man genau diese
politik im koalitionsvertrag fest wo man
200.000 illegale pro jahr erwartet was
für ein verlogener doppelter standard
auf einmal ist man sehr wohl bereit auch
robusten grenzschutz gutzuheißen während
gleichzeitig die deutsche grenze wegen
angeblicher uns
mut barkeit solcher bilder
widerrechtlich ungeschützt bleibt muss
dem bürger ins auge fällt man sich hart
wo es nicht sieht ist polen offen was
für ein verlogener doppelter standard
was für eine unehrliche politik die
türkei forciert den syrien krieg fördert
islamistische kämpfer
sie hat flüchtlingsströme mit
hervorgerufen führt die wir zahlen
sollen
deutschland lässt sich von erdogan am
gängelband führen wird zum spielball
fremder interessen der deutschen
steuerzahler darf milliarden blechen für
merkels weigerung die eigenen grenzen zu
sichern billiger wäre effektiver
grenzschutz nur sachleistungen
schnellere abschiebung
das nehme deutschland seine falsche
anziehungskraft das hielte
wirtschaftsmigranten von der reise ab
herr kollege keine zwischenteil niemand
von denen steckt wo fest sie alle können
zurück in ihre heimatregion und auch
geholfen wird vor ort 100 mal effektiver
und wen immer wieder von den inseln
holen neue kinder werden vorgeschickt
neuer familiennachzug schon geplant
warum gibt es da wohl überhaupt
unbegleitete kinder wer hat sie wofür
dahin gelotst unsere regierung fällt
griechenland in den rücken erzeugt per
abnahme neuen migrationsdruck wir machen
wieder den tugend weltmeister andere
dürfen den bösen grenzschützer geben wir
sagen familienzusammenführung ja aber
richtig die kinder missbraucht als
quartier macher für die tränendrüsen
bilder zurück zu ihren familien in ihre
heimische kultur zu ihren verwandten
jetzt brennen sie gegen die grenze an
mit steinen und brandflaschen mit
tränengasgranaten und bolzenschneidern
wollen wir diese gewalttätigen leute
hier haben keinen durchwinken diesmal
griechenland unterstützen die türkei
heraus aus syrien wiederaufbau beginnen
klare signale an unseren grenzen
illegale migration zahlt sich nicht aus
und wenn die jetzt so lautstark
immigration an der eu grenze zu
verhindern ist dann bitte so was auch
nicht heimlich still und leise täglich
an der deutschen grenze wenn 13.000 an
der griechischen grenze schlimm sind und
sie sind schlimm dann bitte auch keine
13.000 an der deutschen grenze und das
jeden monat bleiben sie gesund
gottfried kuriosen politischer sprecher
der fdp-fraktion es ist vorhin über
sprache im zusammenhang mit
hasskriminalität auch gesprochen worden
über diesen ganzen sektor ich überlasse
ihnen die bewertung dieser rede selbst
nächster redner armin schuster für die
unionsfraktion und da ist er unter
anderem mitglied im innenausschuss aber
auch vorsitzender des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums sicherung der grenzen
kollegen ihre ihre inhaltliche
hilflosigkeit erzeugt eigentlich bloß
noch mitleid also dass das beste was ich
tun kann dass wir ihren antrag aus
mitleid ablehnen meine damen und herren
es gibt vor allem auf den tribünen die
fernsehschirme es gibt hoffnung für
diese ganzen krisen die union regiert
seit 14 jahren dieses land und ich habe
das gefühl wir managen permanent krisen
das aber zu einem großen erfolg
egal was in den letzten 14 jahren
passiert ist deutschland ging aus diesen
krisen immer stärker hervor
und ja meine damen und herren ja die
europäische außengrenze steht unter
stress sie steht unter stress aber sie
steht und dass sie steht liegt daran
dass deutschland eine klare haltung hat
die ist in den letzten wochen von
bundesminister seehofer ganz klar
formuliert wurden auch von der
unionsfraktion wir stehen hinter den
krieg ich möchte die griechen auch mal
loben für das was sie da tun
die neue griechische regierung
eine andere politik und das spürt man
dann das werden sie heute nicht mehr
verstehen wahrscheinlich die nächsten
jahre nicht
es ist ein fächer von maßnahmen den wir
aufgreifen vor ort hilfe für
griechenland ob bundespolizei thw
frontex hilfsgüter es geht um kinder ja
und das kontingent was wir jetzt machen
ist ein europäisches und genau das war
das signal was deutschland erzeugen
wollte kein alleingang keine deutsche
initiative wir wollen dass europa
funktioniert und das ein erfolg wir
haben das geschafft vielleicht werden
zwei hände von länder ja wir haben auch
erdogan eine klare haltung gezeigt es
wird eine fortsetzung dieses abkommens
geben
aber erdogan hat eine klare sprache
jetzt sage ich mal als ganze haus alle
fraktionen haben ihnen politiker und
mitglieder des parlamentarischen
kontrollgremiums es wäre wichtig denn
wir künftig so emotionalisieren wie das
ganz schnell getan haben viele wenn man
sich vorher war den fachleuten bei den
fachpolitikern mal informiert was für
bilder sind das eigentlich wirklich die
gar gezeigt werden und wieviel
choreografie steckt dahinter
dann könnte man auch viel cooler an
manche dinge herangehen das gemeinsame
europäische asylsystem großes lob an den
bundesinnenminister
wir geben nicht nach wir wollen dieses
europäische asylsystem für mich
überhaupt die lösung aller probleme
und dann haben wir auch an der deutschen
grenze meine damen und herren und da ist
die sprache der unions fraktion und des
bundesministers vollkommen kompromisslos
sollte die außengrenze nicht halten dann
wird es an der deutschen binnen grenze
ein bestimmtes regime geben und das wird
in jedem fall auch zurückweisungen
bedeuten diese aussage mache ich aber
nicht in richtung flüchtlinge diese
aussage mache ich in erster linie an
unsere europäischen partner
wir müssen ein klares signal
dass wir an der deutschen binnengrenzen
gegebenenfalls nicht so agieren wie wir
es schon getan haben damit frankreich
damit spanien damit der in der mark
damit benelux kapieren die deutschen
lösen ist für uns nicht mehr wir müssen
uns mit ihnen arrangieren und das
zauberwort heißt gemeinsames
europäisches asylsystem wir machen
flexible lage angepasste
schwerpunktkontrollen auf der grenzlinie
schon seit november über 400
zurückweisungen von menschen mit
aufenthalts- oder einreisverbot sind
eine klare sprache meine damen und
herren wir haben asylzahlen die sind
relativ normal nur gering über dem was
deutschland sonst macht bitte es gibt
außer der ganzen ganz großen kaliber
auch noch das feine florett und wenn man
alles richtig macht dann befindet man
sich mit einer politik der mitte bei dem
was wir gerade tun hohe aufpreis zahlen
die asylzahlen fallen also bitte meine
damen und herren ich will noch einen
satz zu corona sagen ich komme aus einem
ich komme aus einer region wo jetzt
viele nach grenzschließung rufen
übrigens ein wort was auch im parlament
inflationär gebraucht wird ich darf sie
mal daran erinnern dass
grenzschließungen macht nordkorea
vielleicht jumper das kann nicht die
methode sein die wir jetzt aus dem
keller holen auch nicht bei corona ich
setze mich lieber staatssekretär seit
montag intensiv dafür ein dass wir die
grenzkontrollen zu den risikogebieten an
der durch österreich deutsch
schweizerischen und deutsch
französischen grenze intensivieren ja
auch mit corona bezug aber das gesamte
land oder gar europa nahm zu legen die
börsen auf talfahrt zu schicken wenn ich
dir
grenzen schließen dass viele mir bei der
momentanen lage nicht ein
ich bin der festen überzeugung intensive
grenzkontrollen ja aber bitte nicht
grenzen schließen der kollateralschaden
wäre immens und letzter satz peter
altmaier kümmert sich um die
wirtschaftlichen folgen
jens spahn macht einen bomben job als
krisenmanager gesundheit horst seehofer
ist gerade was den antrag anbelangt seit
einem dreiviertel jahr fast nur noch mit
diesem thema befasst viel viel früher
als die meisten hier im haus auch er hat
die lage im griff
ursula von der leyen ist übrigens wissen
sie ja wo der herkommt an klarheit im
moment nicht zu überbieten um meine
damen und herren
nur weil angela merkel nicht jedem tag
jedem hier das köpfchen streichelt
müssen sie nicht unterstellen dass sie
die felgen nicht in der hand hat ich
glaube das sagt das wort union ihr auch
aus wir stehen in krisen zusammen wir
werden sie meistern
das ist mein tipp auch an die
bevölkerung wie die union zusammen
stehen in diesen zeiten dankeschön armin
schuster aus der und für die
cdu/csu-fraktion ohne klinische rednerin
in dieser debatte über die sicherung der
grenzen die auf einem afg antrag beruht
ist linda teuteberg einerseits
generalsekretärin der fdp aber vor allem
auch migrationspolitische sprecherin
ihrer fraktion
sehr geehrter präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen die ereignisse
die bilder die wir derzeit sehen der
zynismus präsident erdogan der mit dem
leben dem schicksal tausender migranten
spielt das ist traurig und erschütternd
und die antwort auf diese
menschenverachtende provokation kann
nicht sein dass wir deutschland und
europa diese erpresserischen politik
nach geben die antwort muss sein dass
wir endlich die notwendigen konsequenzen
ziehen
denn in die wahrheit ist auch das was
wir heute erleben müssen dafür trägt
auch europa und deutschland die
bundesregierung verantwortung
das gilt einmal außen und
sicherheitspolitisch deutschland und
europa stehen am seitenrand während
assad putin und erdogan fakten schaffen
es gilt aber auch für die aufgaben der
bundesregierung in der innenpolitik und
beim gemeinsamen europäischen
asylsystems union und spd haben das seit
2015 nicht geschafft in europa die
notwendigen reformen anzuschieben
das europäische asylsystem zu
reformieren frontex auszubauen und mit
einem gewichtigeren mandat auszustatten
und spätestens jetzt muss die
bundesregierung endlich mit einem neuen
realismus an die migrationspolitik
herangehen und zwar sowohl aus
humanitären gründen als auch aus
europäischer verantwortung wir dürfen
illegale migration wir dürfen die
erpressung erdogans nicht hinnehmen oder
gar belohnen wenn ihr nachzugeben würde
erst recht dazu führen dass sich
hunderttausende weitere migranten auf
den weg nach europa machen
und tausende dabei ihr leben riskieren
und verlieren wir brauchen
wir brauchen eine eine weiterentwicklung
des abkommens mit der türkei das aber
klar macht provokationen und aggression
an der grenze werden nicht hingenommen
und vereinbarungen müssten eingehalten
werden
wer aber glaubt seine vorstellungen von
ungesteuerter migration unseren
europäischen nachbarn aufdrücken zu
können der gefährdet wiederum das
projekt europa für die naivität die da
von einigen auch hier im haus gepflegt
wird gibt es nicht nur in warschau und
budapest sondern auch in paris madrid
stockholm und amsterdam kein verständnis
wir müssen mit den partnern den
kompromiss suchen die eine gemeinsame
europäische migrationspolitik wollen und
wir dürfen die nicht aus der
verantwortung lassen durch alleingänge
die sich dem noch versperren liebe
freundin und da darf sich bis 2015 nicht
wiederholen darf wenn dieser satz auch
2020 stimmen soll dann dürfen wir eben
keine deutschen sonderwege einschlagen
wir müssen eine arbeitsteilung auch in
europa haben wo alle für ordnung und
humanität zuständig sind und wir nicht
darauf hoffen dass andere uns
unangenehme aufgaben abnehmen und
stichwort arbeitsteilung da lohnt auch
ein blick nach österreich die grünen
sind heute schnell dabei das wort
ordnung als überschrift immer wieder zu
benutzen aber wenn es konkret wird
rechtsstaatlich vorschläge zu machen und
vor allem mitzumachen bei sinnvollen
maßnahmen dann schlagen sie sich in die
büsche und das kann man nicht wie in
österreich als koalitions freien raum
definieren den bereich ordnung humanität
und ordnung gehören auch im handeln
zusammen liebe kollegen von den grünen
wir brauchen da einen humanitären
realismus das heißt flüchtlingen zb in
syrien und der türkei schnell und
wirksam zu helfen
das heißt legale wege für migration zu
schaffen und gleichzeitig unsere
europäischen nachbarn und gerade
griechenland in diesen tagen konkret und
tatkräftig zu unterstützen
da ist kritik an griechenland übrigens
bei den zuständen in den lagern an
macht aber beim außen grenzschutz da
verdient griechenland in wort und tat
unsere solidarität
denn denn es gibt keinen
völkerrechtlichen anspruch auf
gewaltsame grenzt durchbrüche wir müssen
in einem rechtsstaatlichen wirksam außen
grenzschutz arbeiten gerade wenn wir
nicht wollen dass sich die frage nach
zurückweisung an der deutschen grenze
stellt wir wollen freizügigkeit in
europa und deshalb brauchen wir wirksame
außen grenzschutz 2020 muss das ja
werden indem wir in deutschland und in
europa endlich ernst machen mit einer
verantwortungsvollen migrationspolitik
frei von naivität dafür mit realismus
mit humanität und ordnung findet linda
teuteberg migrationspolitische
sprecherin der fdp fraktion und auch
generalsekretärin ihrer partei in dieser
debatte über ein fdp antrag zur
sicherung der grenzen der europäischen
aber auch der deutschen und dazu jetzt
im grütt aus der spd fraktion in den
hier vorliegenden drei seiten euch den
text steht das wort illegal an sage und
schreibe 19 stellen 19 mal auf drei
seiten und das im zusammenhang mit
menschen lassen sie mich deshalb gleich
zu beginn einer rede in aller
deutlichkeit eines sagen menschen sind
nicht illegal niemals und nirgendwo auf
der welt
die bilder der letzten tage von denen
auch immer sie erzeugt wurden von der
türkisch griechischen grenze haben uns
alle erstaunlich gänze hat bekommt denn
das kalt lässt
er ist kein mensch liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen und ich sage es ihnen ganz klar
ich habe mich nicht an solche bilder
gewöhnt und ich will mich nicht an
solche menschenunwürdigen zustände
gewöhnen wir seit einigen tagen an der
türkisch-griechischen grenze zu sehen
sind
deshalb bin ich sehr froh dass auf druck
der spd am letzten wochenende im
koalitionsausschuss beschlossen wurde
dass deutschland schwer kranke und
unbegleitete kinder und sehr zum
erschreckender afd
auch deren eltern von den griechischen
inseln und im grenzgebiet zwischen
griechenland und der türkei aufnehmen
wird weil es buchstäblich um leben und
tod geht lassen sie uns deshalb an allen
stellen alles dafür tun damit wir lieber
gestern als heute diese kinder aus
dieser misere befreien können denn sie
können rein gar nichts dafür dass sie
zum spielball eines geopolitischen
konfliktes geworden sind am ende noch
ein satz zu ihrem antrag
sie bedienen naturgemäß schon wieder
hier rechtes klientel ansturm
migrantenströme gefährliche
migrantengruppen kämpfer und so weiter
das ist blanker unsinn
frontex verzeichnet weniger unerlaubte
grenzübertritte nach europa wir reden
von 92 prozent weniger als zu hochzeiten
der flüchtlingsbewegung im jahr 2015 92
prozent weniger
auch in deutschland sinkt die zahl der
unerlaubten einreisen wir haben immer
weniger asylanträge zu verzeichnen aber
fakten interessieren sie nicht ich weiß
was sie versuchen ist einfach nur billig
und schäbig und es gelingt dann auch
dieses mal nicht
und vor allem ist das was sie da
schreiben schlichtweg unwahr
sie hätten gestern im innenausschuss
aufpassen sollen da haben ihnen der
staatssekretär im bundesinnenministerium
und der vertreter des auswärtigen amtes
noch erklärt dass sich die situation an
der grenze seit einigen tagen komplett
beruhigt haben und dass kein einziger
asylsuchende auf den griechischen inseln
neu angekommen ist und dass die türkei
wieder das eu türkei abkommen anwendet
und die rück geführten migranten
aufnehmen
wir haben außerdem zehn beamte vor ort
zur unterstützung von frontex auch an
der bulgarisch türkischen grenze war und
ist wieder ruhe eingekehrt
warum sollte frontex also diese grenze
sichern
die beamten haben sicherlich besseres zu
tun als an menschenleeren grenzübergänge
nach einer migranten zu warten was sie
schreiben ist deshalb einfach unsinn
deshalb fordere ich sie auch verbal
abzurüsten gerade in diesen zeiten wenn
das überhaupt möglich ist bei ihrem
geschäftsmodell
ein letzter punkt den ich noch
ansprechen möchte wir haben ja immer
gesagt zur sicherung eines europas ohne
grand ohne grenzen gehört ein wirksamer
schutz der europäischen außengrenzen
wir wollen daher frontex stärken und zu
einer echten leistungsfähigen
grenzschutz polizei weiter entwickeln
richtig verstandener schutz bedeutet
aber nicht dass april ging von grenzen
wir brauchen mehr kontrolle und ordnung
bei der bekämpfung von
menschenschmugglern und schleusern ein
besserer brandschutz muss einhergehen
mit partnerschaften mit den
transitländern und den herkunftsstaaten
unter anderem über legale zuwanderung
möglichkeiten und wirtschaftliche hilfen
auch ein mehr grenzschutz werden
menschen aus sorge um ihr leben oder
ihre freiheit berechtigterweise schutz
suchen für verfolgte flüchtlinge aus
krisengebieten muss europa offen bleiben
denn asyl ist ein menschenrecht
für diese fälle brauchen wir gemeinsame
anstrengungen aller aber mindestens der
willigen mitgliedstaaten der
europäischen union der zelle habe das
bundesinnenministerium und alle
beteiligten ressorts dass sie den
koalitionsbeschluss deshalb zügig
umsetzen
vielen dank nächster redner kollege dr
andré hahn die linke
[Applaus]
herr präsident meine damen und herren
der vorliegende antrag der afg zeigt
einmal mehr wofür diese partei im kern
steht die fdp steht für ausgrenzung
abschottung und rassismus und nicht nur
die linke sondern die große mehrheit in
diesem haus stellt sich dem entschieden
entgegen
fakt ist an der türkisch-griechischen
grenze spielen sich gegenwärtig
dramatische szenen ab familien mit
kleinen kindern werden von der
griechischen polizei mit tränengas und
blendgranaten beschlossen
die griechische küstenwache gibt anstatt
zu helfen warnschüsse auf
flüchtlingsboote ab und riskiert mit
gefährlichen manövern dass diese kentern
in einem beispiellosen vorgang setzt die
griechische regierung das asylrecht
außer kraft und lässt schutzsuchende
dies nach europa geschafft haben ohne
prüfung der flucht gründe zurück in die
türkei abschieben
dieses vorgehen der griechischen
regierung ist zutiefst inhuman weil es
die not der betroffenen menschen die
erst auf geheiß des türkischen
präsidenten erdogan an die grenze
verbracht wurden ignoriert und sie
weiter in die verzweiflung treibt
das vorgehen griechenlands ist zudem
eklatant rechtswidrig und die
bundesregierung weiß das ganz genau ich
zitiere aus einer vom innenministerium
erstellten weisung vom vierten märz für
den sonderrat der eu für justiz und
inneres das heißt das zitat artikel 78
absatz 3 des vertrags über die
arbeitsweise der eu stellt aus deutscher
sicht keine
rechtsgrundlage für einseitige maßnahmen
der mitgliedstaaten da hier aussetzung
der annahme von asylanträgen humanitäres
völker und unionsrecht gebietet das
recht auf asyl ende des zitats
griechenland bricht also eu-recht doch
anstatt das zumindest öffentlich oder
wenigstens diplomatisch zu kritisieren
nennt innenminister seehofer das
vorgehen griechenlands an der grenze
sehr gut und bezeichnet die aussetzung
des asylrechts gar wider besseres wissen
als in ordnung das ist völlig
inakzeptabel
unsere forderung als linke ist ganz
eindeutig die eu kommission muss endlich
auf die einhaltung europäischer und
internationaler regeln drängen die
illegalen zurückweisungen an der
griechischen grenze müssen sofort
gestoppt werden meiner krankheit meiner
kranker fraktionskollege michael brandt
der heute eigentlich auch reden wollte
war gerade vor ort und hätte ihn mit
sicherheit schlimme schicksale von dort
schildern können höchst dramatisch ist
nach wie vor auch die situation auf den
griechischen ägäisinsel das
flüchtlingslager mobil war ursprünglich
für 3000 menschen ausgelegt derzeit
leben dort circa 25.000 ohne absehbare
perspektive unter menschenunwürdigen
bedingungen ohne ausreichend den zugang
zu medizinischer versorgung zu
lebensmitteln oder zustrom in einer
reportage der zdf sendung frontal 21 von
dieser woche erklärte eine frau
wir leben hier wie die tiere etwas nicht
mal tiere leben so ende des zitats dich
sage wir dürfen vor diesem leid nicht
länger die augen verschließen auf lesbos
kontrolliert ein rassistischer mod teile
der insel schulen und unterkünfte werden
angezündet
rechtsextreme machen jagd auf
journalisten und humanitäre helfer und
manche hilfsorganisationen haben schon
aufgegeben und ihre mitarbeiter
evakuiert das sind inzwischen eine
handvoll leute linke humanisten die
ehrenamtlich versuchen auf lesbos das
letzte bisschen menschlichkeit zu wahren
ein guter bekannter von mir der dort
mithilft wurde von einem achtjährigen
jungen kürzlich gefragt ob er nicht sein
vater sein wolle
ich finde das erschütternd und der
antrag der fdp dagegen ist frei frei von
jeglicher empathie für die situation der
schutzsuchenden und rückt diese sogar
noch pauschal in die nähe von
kriminellen oder terroristischen
organisationen dass die afg so
argumentiert überrascht mich nicht bei
anderen erwarte ich jedoch mehr
sensibilität das hat sage ich auch in
richtung von frau von der leyen fliegen
sie nicht mit dem hubschrauber über die
grenze und die flüchtlingslager sondern
informieren sie sich persönlich vor ort
dann werden auch sie begreifen dass die
zustände dort schlichtweg unhaltbar sind
und die eu ihre strategie korrigieren
muss unsere position als linker
unsere position als linke ist klar der
sogenannte flüchtling stil war ein
schwerer fehler
wir dürfen uns von erdogan weder
erpressbar machen noch erpressen lassen
und schon deshalb verbietet sich jeder
neuauflage oder überarbeitung dieses
abkommens und nehmen sie endlich zur
kenntnis
trotz aller zum teil auch rechtswidrigen
bestrebungen geflüchtete vom zugang nach
europa abzuhalten ist die
hilfsbereitschaft in deutschland
weiterhin erfreulich groß rund 140
kommunen in deutschland haben sich zu
sicheren häfen und damit zur weiteren
aufnahme von geflüchteten bereit
erklären und allein die rot rot grün
regierte bundeshauptstadt hat aktuell
2000 plätze angeboten und dagegen ist
das geschafft hat der großen koalition
um die anzahl und aufnahme unbegleiteter
kinder die von den griechischen inseln
geholt werden sollen einfach nur
unwürdig
meine damen und herren wir dürfen nicht
warten
es ist irgendwann vielleicht eine
europäische lösung gibt und eine
verteilung die immer wieder gefordert
wird die bundesregierung muss jetzt
handeln und die zusammenarbeit mit den
aufnahmebereiten kommunen suchen die
zustände auf den inseln und an der
griechischen grenze sind unhaltbar
die aufnahme der dort gestrandeten
gebietet das recht und die
menschlichkeit andré hahn war das für
die fraktion die linke und wir stellen
fest dass man die lage auf den
griechischen inseln in den lagern mit
flüchtlingen aber auch die lage an der
türkisch-griechischen grenze sehr
unterschiedlich wahrnehmen und auch sehr
unterschiedlich schildern kann
annalena baerbock ist generell
vorsitzende bündnis 90 die grünen aus
die größte lehrer aus unserer geschichte
kaputtmachen wollen demokratie die
allgemeinverbindlichkeit von
menschenrechten
das wissen wir leider alle wir hier
gemeinsam im parlament dass es der
auftrag unseres grundgesetzes wollen
genau das gegenteil
dieses gemeinsame europa als einheit in
vielfalt als raum der freiheit der
sicherheit und des rechts bewahren und
schützen aber dafür meine sehr verehrten
damen und herren reicht es nicht in
diesen tagen auch nicht in so einer
debatte sich selber auf die schulter zu
klopfen und sagen es ist schon alles gut
nichts ist gut gerade an der
europäischen außengrenzen
schauen sie sich die bilder anja und man
muss sie sich an stellen nicht nur die
griechischen inseln sondern das werte
fundament dieser gemeinsamen
europäischen union steht dieser tage in
flammen
das gewaltmonopol des staates ist
ausgesetzt und zwar auf grundlage dessen
das versprechen die wir als deutsch als
europäer gegeben haben zu geordneten
strukturen nicht eingehalten wurden
kontingente von 2016 von den
griechischen inseln haben nicht mehr
stattgefunden
das ist teil dieses problems der
heutigen tage journalisten angeles
gefürchtete werden auf lesbos
angegriffen wenn die polizei angerufen
wird dann wird wieder aufgelegt one
happy family ein familienzentrum wo
schulbildung wo gesundheitsversorgung
geleistet wurde
das stand vor drei tagen in flammen auf
lesbos in moria leben 20.000 menschen im
dreck ausgelegt für 3000 traumatisierte
kinder spielen zwischen müllbergen
etliches in suizid gefährdet eigentlich
müsste diese ganze insel
angesichts der sicherheitslage dort vor
ort evakuiert werden
wir haben daher ein
zwei wochen hier vorgeschlagen
fünftausender als deutsche als deutschen
anteil zu nehmen und zwar nicht nur als
frage von humanität und das zieht ihn ja
gerne alle jetzt humanität und ordnung
sondern auch als frage von sicherheit
von rechtsstaatlichkeit und von
geordneten strukturen dort vor ort
humanität und ordnung das ist kein
gegensatz
das bedingt einander das sehen wir nicht
nur auf lesbos das sehen wir auch an der
griechisch-türkischen grenze das
menschenverachtende spiel von herrn
erdogan funktioniert doch vor allem weil
die eu in angst und schrecken verfällt
und weil sie in so einer situation mit
tränengas und blendgranaten auf männer
frauen und kinder schießt das ist das
gegenteil von ordnung das ist chaos
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
das ist ein massiver verstoß gegen
grundrechte
das ist beschämend und ja ich sag sie
auch ganz deutlich weil sie ja gerne
auch von teilen der regierungsfraktion
irgendwie die intellektuelle fähigkeit
von uns grünen das können wir verkraften
aber von vielen menschen in diesem land
offensichtlich unterschätzen
niemand sagt dass heißt offene grenzen
grenzschutz ist wichtig und richtig
europa ohne binnengrenzen funktioniert
nur mit einer kontrolle der gemeinsamen
außengrenzen
aber meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren es ist das wesen einer grenze
dass es legale grenzübergängen gibt und
es wird ja dieser tage auch von seiten
der regierung hier immer wieder das
urteil des europäischen gerichtshof für
menschenrechte zitiert bitte lesen die
das einmal genau wir sind ein
rechtsstaat
da kann man nicht recht auslegen wie es
einem gerade in den 17
dieses urteil macht mehr als deutlich
schutzbedürftigkeit nach artikel 3 der
europäischen menschenrechtskonvention
können sie einmal den mund halten meine
güte schutzbedürftigkeit der artikel 3
der europäischen
menschenrechtskonvention bedeutet ein
effektiver zugang über ein reisewege
lesen sie rang nummer 201 und 212 da
steht ganz explizit drin auch an der
europäischen außengrenzen darf es kein
niemandsland und rechtsfreien räume
geben meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren und daher in die debatte hätte
ich heute von ihnen als
regierungsfraktion erwartet hätte ich
von dieser bundesregierung erwartet dass
sie klar und deutlich macht eine
komplette abwicklung der grenzübergänge
systematische push push becks aussetzung
des asylrechts
da sagt man nicht da stehen wir in
sympathie daneben sondern das ist nicht
vereinbar mit dem grundsatz der
zurückweisung aus der genfer
flüchtlingskonvention die europäische
menschenrechtskonvention wird sie
gebrochen als nicht vereinbar mit der
auflage starten sie eine zwischen folge
der kollegen von storch nein und es ist
nicht vereinbar
es ist nicht vereinbar von ihrem
vielzitierten frontex die frontex der
verordnung in artikel 36 und in artikel
43 basiert darauf dass die europäische
menschenrechtskonvention 1 feldmann
herten damen vom netz die suche und ich
sage an dieser stelle auch deutlich wer
das recht ignoriert weil es politisch
nicht opportun ist der verabschiedet
sich von einem rechtsstaat und der
stärke nicht den rechtsstaat an dieser
stelle und diese äußerung ja die hätte
ich mir gewünscht von der eu
kommissionspräsidenten gewünscht von
ihnen als regierungsfraktionen wer heute
artikel 18 der europäischen
grundrechte-charta aussetzt was sagt er
dann wenn morgen artikel 14 oder zwölf
ausgesetzt wird wenn das recht auf
meinungsfreiheit ausgesetzt wird wir
können den viel beschworenen
rechtsstaats mechanismus der eu in die
tonne treten meine sehr verehrten damen
und herren wenn wir anfangen grundrechte
endlich auszusetzen und wir haben
zahlreiche vorschläge gemacht heute zu
handeln es reicht nicht ein neues
asylsystem zu beschwören
sie müssen ihm hier und heute mit der
türkei darüber sprechen dass die
versorgung vor ort gesichert wird dass
ihr fixe kontingente aufnehmen und dass
wir zu unserem grundrecht stehen und ich
sage an dieser stelle abschließend auch
sehr deutlich dieses wegschauen hat auch
dramatische innenpolitische sicherheits
folgen es sind gerade rechtsextreme auf
die insel nach griechenland gefahren
einer hat auf facebook gepostet gebt mir
eine 60 und ausreichend munition ich
werde den ganzen menschlichen abschaum
an der grenze ab klein liebe
bundesregierung wie kann es sein dass
identität dass rechtsextreme in diesen
tagen nach lesbos ausreisen dürfen wir
brauchen hier aus reisesperren für
extremisten die gewaltbereit sind in
diesen tagen dass es unsere
verantwortung als deutscher bundestag
und als deutsche bundesregierung
herzlichen dank annalena baerbock
vorsitzende der partei bündnis 90 die
grünen hier im bundestag in der debatte
über den fdp-antrag zusicherungen der
grenzen und in dieser debatte spitze
detlef seif für die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen meine damen und herren
in einem punkt ist den vorliegenden
antrag natürlich recht zu geben das
verhalten der türkei ist unzumutbar
das ist nicht hinnehmbar dass die türkei
den grenzschutz zur griechischen grenze
vorübergehend aussetzte und aktiv wir
haben erkenntnisse darüber an der
verbringung von migranten an die
türkisch griechische grenze mitwirkte
aber nicht akzeptabel ist genauso auch
das fortdauernde beleidigungen und
rhetorik gegenüber griechenland erfolg
und auch vor allem die aufforderung an
die griechen die migranten ziehen zu
lassen denn die wollen ja ohnehin nicht
in griechenland bleiben
herr erdogan lassen sie diese rhetorik
lassen sie diese beleidigung diese
bedrohungen und diese nicht hinnehmbaren
maßnahmen und kommen sie zurück zu einem
verhalten was wir unter freunden und
partnern erwarten dürfen
das jüngste verhalten darf uns aber
nicht über eines hinwegtäuschen die
türkei leistet bei der bewältigung der
migrationsströme großartiges sie leistet
bei der aufnahme und versorgung von
flüchtlingen einen großen beitrag nach
angaben der vereinten nationen fast 3,6
millionen syrische flüchtlinge fast
330.000 flüchtlinge aus anderen ländern
die unterstützung der eu hat geholfen
dass 100 projekte über 100 projekte auf
den weg gebracht werden konnten
flüchtlingszentren 180 schulen wurden
neu gebaut 179 krankenhäuser und
gesundheitszentren sind bereit gestellt
und weitere infrastruktur entwickelt
aber trotz erheblicher eigenleistung der
türkei reichen die finanziellen mittel
nicht aus um allen kindern bildung
ermöglichen was aufgrund der
perspektivlosigkeit natürlich ein großes
maß an radikalisierung gefahr bedeutet
hier muss dringend nachgebessert werden
diejenigen die behaupten dass das eu
türkei abkommen tot sei sollten sich vor
augen halten in letzter konsequenz
würden wir alle flüchtlinge die sich
zurzeit in tour in der türkei aufhalten
im stich lassen und für würden große
zusätzliche migrationsströme in bewegung
setzen
meine damen und herren das jüngste
verhalten der türkei hat uns aber auch
nochmals deutlich und zum wiederholten
maßen vor augen geführt wie schnell sich
die verhältnisse an der eu-außengrenze
ändern können und wenn man mal genau
hinschaut ich habe heute wieder den
begriff schutzsuchende flüchtlinge so
oft gehört
es handelte sich nach den vorliegenden
erkenntnissen zumindest weit überwiegend
bei den 16.000 menschen vor ort um
menschen die in der türkei bereits
schutz gefunden haben und versorgt
wurden es sind keine flüchtlinge es sind
keine person die nach dem geist europas
bei uns schutz beanspruchen sollen und
nennen wir es beim namen es handelt sich
ganz überwiegend um menschen die ihre
lebenssituation verbessern wollen um
menschen die wirtschafts migration
betreiben wollen
und das können wir nicht unterstützen
wir wollen die unterstützen die unseren
schutz brauchen und die tatsächlich
verfolgt sind und sie merken nicht dass
sie durch das übermaß verhindern dass
tatsächlich die verfolgten auch diesen
schutzanspruch erhalten
bei den menschen die nicht verfolgt sind
wollen wir will die europäische union
entscheiden wer zu uns kommt in
deutschland zb nach dem fachkräfte
einwanderungsgesetz und nach der blue
card richtlinie und wir entscheiden das
und nicht die menschen die ihre
lebenssituation verbessern wurde die eu
kommission sollte prüfen und sei
dringend anzuraten dem positiven
vorschlag der bundesregierung zu folgen
dem konzeptpapier denn nur mit einer
verbindlichen vollständigen erfassung
registrierung vorprüfung an den grenzen
und auch zurückschiebung vor ort der
menschen die erkennbar kein
schutzanspruch haben können wir dem
missbrauch wirksam begegnen und
eigentlich da werden sie mir jetzt nicht
zustimmen ist die bundesregierung auf
einem guten weg und macht bereits das
was hier in den kernforderungen
aufstellen
deutschland wird selbstverständlich
griechenland weitere zusätzliche
unterstützungsleistungen zukommen lassen
und der bundesinnenminister hat mit
seinem tweet dass die grenzen europas
für die flüchtlinge aus der türkei nicht
geöffnet sind und dass das auch für
deutschland gilt ein klares und
wirkungsvolles signal entsendet wir
wissen wie groß sich kleine botschaften
in der heutigen welt entfalten und
entwickeln können und das war genau der
richtige hinweis bei fortdauernden
mängeln das hat der kollege schuster
auch schon gesagt werden wir natürlich
innerhalb deutschlands wenn mängel bei
der eu-außengrenze bestehen die
maßnahmen fortführen wir wissen die
kommission kritisiert dass wir an
freizügigkeit aber dennoch klares signal
an die kommission wir sind auf einem
guten weg aber wir erwarten dass die eu
außengrenzen insgesamt wirksam
unterstützt werden deshalb abschließende
bemerkung die bundesregierung leistet
gute arbeit und braucht nun wirklich
keine unterstützung durch die afg und
aufrufe vielen dank meine damen und
herren es ist für die fraktion cdu csu
und ihm folgt noch ein weiterer redner
andy powell hampl der auch
außenpolitischer sprecher seiner
fraktion ist präsident damen und herren
die mit extrem im deutschen bundestag
die bundesregierung meine damen und
herren muss mit dem klammerbeutel
gepudert sein überhaupt noch mit herrn
erdogan zu verhandeln wenn wir uns die
situation vorstellen dass ein türkischer
staatspräsident militärisch und
völkerrechtswidrig in ein nachbarland
interveniert dadurch einen
flüchtlingsstrom erzeugt und diese
flüchtlinge sollen milliarden
unterstützung als auch für herrn erdogan
in europa auf dem hirnrissig kann die
deutsche politik nicht handelt meine
damen und herren
es wurde eben zu recht mehrfach erwähnt
sie können das in allen deutschen
sendern sehen
da werden von den journalisten die
migranten interviewt und sie sagen es
offen keiner sagt er kommt als
flüchtling jeder sagt er möchte in
deutschland arbeiter die keine schöne
ausbildung man könnte gut wohnen in
deutschland nicht einer beruft sich auf
den atom paragrafen des grundgesetzes
lernen sie von den flüchtlingen und
werden sie ihre ziele kennen sie selber
definieren es so und dann ist in der tat
zwanghaft für die bundesregierung dass
wir einmal die griechen unterstützen
müssen und natürlich auch unsere eigenen
grenzen sollte es nicht funktionieren
sichern müssen allerdings das was wir in
der zeit in griechenland leisten wir
waren dort gewesen wir waren in
quartieren wir waren in bosnien und bahn
zum schluss auf samos in griechenland da
konnten sie sehen was die deutschen
derzeit leisten mit einem boot aus
rostock deutsche bundespolizisten ganze
kerle die das da gesteuert habe aber
eingeschränkt von all den restriktionen
die sie akzeptieren mussten und von uns
genau erklärt haben das von der
türkischen grenze 1,6 kilometer ist eine
seemeile von der türke von den
griechischen inseln entfernt die
flüchtlinge über transportiert werden
morgens und abends 40.000 dollar ist ein
transport mit 40 personen manchmal sind
auch 70 bis 80 dann ist noch mehr geld
die türkischen behörden kassieren mit
das ist die realität derzeit in der
türkei unterstütze videoanbieter küsten
die schlepperbanden und kriminellen mit
unserer hinhaltenden politik und dann
ist es unsere aufgabe meine damen und
herren die griechen viel stärker zu
unterstützen mit hundertschaften von
bundespolizei mit bundesweiten die dort
unten mit den griechen gemeinsamen zum
einsatz kommt um diesem ansturm
abzuwehren
und ich kann nur eins sagen die griechen
sind ein weltoffenes volk eine alte
skifahrer nation die haben uns erzählt
am anfang haben sie viele flüchtlinge
aufgenommen sie kennen sie seit ein paar
tausend jahren muss man auch dazu sagt
und heute sagen sie wir können das nicht
mehr
wir sind völlig überlastet
boß in samos und anderswo und dann sehen
die griechen nicht irgendwelche
radikalen gruppen auf den inseln die
menschen die sagen nein die gehen auf
die straße wir wollen diesen
implikationen flut nicht mehr auf
unseren inseln haben und da haben sie
völlig recht und das willst du
unterstützt mal dabei und last niessl
hat schon ein land gegeben dass genau
diese migrationspolitik einmal sehr
erfolgreich verhindert hat das ist
australien
der slogan yes you back australia home
und das hat man im gesamten asiatischen
raum verstanden nachdem man alle
zurückgeschickt hat die einmal versucht
haben an australischen gestorben zu
landen
man hat es in den ländern propagiert und
das wäre eine aufgabe der deutschen
botschaften die kunden zu tun im nahen
osten in allen ländern jubel selber mc
germany nur um dann funktioniert das
auch meine damen und herren dankeschön
dafür die politik dem trio paul ampel
für die hfg fraktion und in folge lind
aus der spd fraktion
[Applaus]
herr präsident
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen grenzen
und damit auch grants setzungen und
grenzöffnungen sind vielleicht die
zentralen fragen dieser tage und deshalb
erlauben sie mir bevor ich eine
entsprechende grenzziehung gegenüber der
afg vollziehe kurz noch etwas zu den
ausführungen von frau bär burg zu sagen
zwei anmerkungen
erstens sie erweckten leicht den
eindruck dass die bundesregierung
irgendwie verantwortlich seien dafür
dass rechtsextreme aus deutschland oder
europa auf die griechische insel reisen
ich halte das für ein nicht legitimes
argument zumal auch in dortmund gerade
die polizei beispielsweise alles macht
und gruppen zu hindern wenn jemand in
einem verantwortung zusammenhang gesetzt
werden kann dann sind es solche reden
der fdp wie sie gerade gehört haben und
solche anträge wie wir sie gerade
beraten
das ist die kausalkette und das zweite
noch
sie führt mir aus was sie sich gewünscht
hätten und erwartet hätten von den
koalitionsfraktionen von der regierung
und haben viele auch richtige humanitäre
forderungen nach rechtliche forderungen
benannt ich erinnere mich gut wie wir
bei dem thema der seenotrettung
überfraktionelle zusammengearbeitet
haben um gegen die kriminalisierung der
seenotrettung anzukämpfen und für einen
verteilungsmechanismus zu arbeiten ich
hätte von ihnen erwartet dass sie diese
form der kollegialität im parlament auch
in bezug auf die situation in
griechenland ausüben
stattdessen stellt die grüne fraktion
eine namentliche abstimmung
und nicht nur das nicht nur das sie
haben dann auch in schaubildern
kenntlich gemacht wer wie abgestimmt hat
ich finde dass diese art der
auseinandersetzung nicht zwingt ein
gemeinschaftlicher ergebnis förderlich
ist und dazu beiträgt das ist meine
wahrnehmung dessen
sie dient sie dient durchaus der
selbstprofilierung aber sie ist ein
bärendienst gegenüber den in der spd
fraktion auf der cdu-fraktion die
natürlichen mit dieser frage ring wie
sollte es auch anders sein jeder in
diesem raum muss in dieser situation mit
sich ringen und es gibt eben nicht die
einfache rettende antwort darauf gibt
aber zur grenzziehung in bezug auf die
fdp fraktion in ihrem antrag der jahr
trunken ist von formulierungen wie
ansturm menschenströme und systematisch
flüchtlinge ersetzt durch illegale
migranten
man schaue sich einmal den film den film
zur vorstellung dieses antrag ist
inoffiziellen afd film zur vorstellung
dieses antrages grenzen sichern an und
dann guckt man in die kommentare
da findet sich unter anderem die
formulierung eines schreibers namens
störtebeker xyz der darin dann deutlich
ausführt ich zitiere was soll der
blödsinn mit den kindern die holen doch
sowieso ihre ganzen glänzt nach
familienzusammenführungen für muslime
heißt nicht nur ehemann und kinder
sondern neffen nichten großeltern und so
weiter führt er das aus dass eindeutige
verlängerung ihrer diktion ich fasse
zusammen dieses zitat die afg es mit
diesem antrag der parlamentarische
vorhof von hasskriminalität insofern ist
dieser antrag auch in einem direkten
zusammenhang mit unserer vorherigen
debatte und dann verweisen aber im
zweiten der kommentatoren dieser
kommentar ist nicht gelöscht worden ist
nicht gelöscht worden
von ganz weiter er lautet folgendermaßen
schicken wir doch bezogen auf der
ausführung von encurio 30.000 soldaten
nach griechenland knallen die ich
zitiere knallen sie das ganze gelände ab
wenn millionenfach illegal die grenze
durchbrochen wird dann
rechtfertigt das den einsatz von napalm
maschinengewehr und panzern egal ob baby
frau oder feiner kerl
zitat ende so etwas steht unter dem
antrag der fdp-fraktion wer jetzt noch
als bürger als besorgter bürger
diese partei unterstützt und wählt der
tipp auch in eine
verantwortungsgemeinschaft mit diesen
ausführungen
insofern sollte ernsthaft gesetzgebung
zur untergrabung der demokratie und der
menschlichkeit innerhalb des parlaments
beraten und noch heute ist dazu noch
weitere stationen mit dieser diktion
befördern sie ja geradezu jede form der
verhetzung auch in diesem land sie
beschleunigen all das denken was die
vermeintlich anklagen wollen sie sagen
grenzen sichern aber sie wünschen sich
doch grenzen öffnen und die schicken
heimlich doch dankesbriefe an herrn
erdogan
denn das ist doch was sie wollen sie
wollen diese bilder in griechenland und
sie wollen flüchtlinge in diesem mann
damit sie ihre hits politik weiter
betreiben können wir aber und ich habe
betont wir können es sich einfach machen
und wir sind tatsächlich als koalition
nicht der meinung dass es eine globale
freizügigkeit ist weil wir glauben dass
freizügigkeit ein bürgerrecht ist
bezogen auf deutschland auf die eu aber
kein menschenrecht
das bedeutet aber auch dass solche
grenzen wenn wir sie setzten
durchlässige sein müssen durchlässige
sein müssen in bezug auf ein geltenden
asylrecht und auch durchlässig in bezug
auf arbeitsmigration das ist genau die
aufgaben und deshalb können wir nicht
dauerhaft akzeptieren und werden es auch
nicht dass zuerst in ungarn und jetzt
auch in griechenland das asylrecht außer
kraft gesetzt wird dass das verbot
kollektive ausweisung dass das gebot
asylverfahren durchzuführen das
rechtsschutz nicht gilt wenn wir das
nicht tun verkauft in der tat europa
seine seele und sein gewissen aber genau
deswegen arbeiten wir und das ist keine
triviale aufgabe für ein
funktionierendes europäisches asylsystem
deshalb haben die regierungskoalition
sich für ein aufnahmeprogramm
entschlossen von 1500 das aber nicht die
abschließende antwort sein kann und
deshalb bringen wir darum dass wir
sichere außengrenzen haben aber solche
an denen die menschenrechte gelten und
dass die binnengrenzen in diesem land
offen bleiben herr schuster sprach von
corona und wir sind ja alle getrieben
davon und die afd
schämt sich nicht mal sogar das thema
corona in bezug auf flüchtlinge zu
instrumentalisieren
aber täuschen wir uns nicht die größte
herausforderung der gefährlichste wir
uns in diesem land bei allen witterungen
gewerbe ist nicht corona das ist der
virus des hasses den solche anträge und
solche reden wie wir sie gerade hört ab
verbreiten und wenn wir gegen diesen
virus nicht ein schutzprogramm
entwickeln dann ist es um europa
geschehen wegen der rechtsextremisten in
diesem parlament in diesem land und in
vielen europäischen ländern vielen dank
blind für die spd-fraktion da ist er
sprecher der arbeitsgruppe demokratie
und etliche titel der debatte über einen
antrag zum thema sicherung der grenzen
hintergrund ist natürlich die aktuelle
lage an der griechisch-türkischen grenze
und dazu haben wir jetzt benjamin
strasser aus der fdp-fraktion richtig
herausgestellt den zusammenhang zwischen
offenen grenzen innerhalb europas und
dem schutz der eu außengrenzen
deshalb ist es auch nicht dass wir heute
noch mal über dieses thema intensiv
diskutieren und sprechen
offene grenzen innerhalb von europa sind
eine zentrale eigenschaft der
europäischen union ist aber auch eine
zentrale errungenschaft für meine
generation hier in diesem haus sitzen
kolleginnen und kollegen wie ich die mit
solchen offenen grenzen aufgewachsen
sind und ich mag es zu stehen das alte
weiße männer am rechten rand es nicht
begreifen wollen was offenbar grenzen
für die lebenschancen
jugendlichen hier in deutschland
bedeuten aber dass diese bundesregierung
dass diese bundesregierung in den
letzten jahren so zögerlich war bei
einer gemeinsamen europäischen strategie
dass sie so zögerlich ist wenn es um die
steuerung und ordnung von migration geht
und dass sie so zögerlich ist wenn es um
den erhalt offener binnengrenzen geht
das ist für mich wirklich unverständlich
diese situation die wir in griechenland
erleben die hängt auch damit zusammen
dass man offensichtlich in den letzten
jahren untätig war was europäische
lösungen angeht schon zum 2015 war klar
dass dublin drei reformbedürftig war
seit fünf jahren ist uns dringend klar
dass wir eine gemeinsame abgestimmte
europäische migrations und
flüchtlingspolitik verbrauchen geschehen
ist aber leider kaum etwas und dort wo
etwas geschieht dauert es mindestens
zehn jahre bis wir in die umsetzung
kommen lieber herr kollege schuster sie
haben vor allem auch die brüderlichkeit
und schwester lichkeit innerhalb der
unionsfraktion reguliert also wenn ich
noch mal erinnern darf 2018 so viel mit
brüderlichkeit schwesterlich kite war da
nicht wenn wir gucken was für einen
bizarren streit gewinner der
unionsfraktion erlebt haben zwischen 1
innenminister sie moderiere
fraktionsgemeinschaft verlassen wollte
und wenige monate nach antritt der
bundesregierung diese wieder sprengen
wollte wegen einer handvoll flüchtlinge
an der deutschen außengrenze aber beide
haben ja danach betont sowohl die frau
bundeskanzlerin wie auch der
bundesinnenminister
wir wollen jetzt in europa in geas wir
wollen jetzt eine weiterentwicklung von
dublin wir wollen jetzt den aufbau einer
gemeinsamen grenzschutzagentur frontex
was ist dann passiert in den letzten
zwei jahren wenn wir mal auf ihre
leistungsbilanz anschauen nach diesem
sturm im bayrischen wasserglas
fehlanzeige
gemeinsames europäisches asylrecht
da bin 44
frau frontex fast fehlanzeige
sie haben sich jetzt darauf verständigt
bis 2027 eine tolle mannschaft von
10.000 kräften zu installieren und
müssen aber in der gleichen ebene
ausschusssitzung noch höheren aus reihen
der unionsfraktion eine abordnung von
bundespolizisten in richtung frontex sei
eine schwächung der sicherheit
deutschlands das gegenteil davon ist
richtig die abordnung ist eine stärkung
deutschlands ist in unserem interesse
dass frontex gestärkt wird deswegen
erwarten wir dass diese europäische rat
präsidentschaft im herbst gibt's dazu
genutzt wird endlich eine gemeinsame
europäische linie zu finden die
vorzeichen
die sind schlecht wir haben eine
bundeskanzlerin die unabgestimmt im jahr
2015 gehandelt hat das uns bis heute
nachhängen
wir haben an den entscheidenden stellen
im kanzleramt und im innenministerium
personen die jetzt schon angekündigt
haben in einem jahr gar nicht mehr in
diesen positionen sein zu wollen
unter diesen bedingungen eine lösung zu
erreichen es schwierig sie haben uns
aber an ihrer seite
das ist dringender denn je vielen
herzlichen dank benjamin strasser aus
der fdp fraktion in dieser debatte über
den antrag der eifel die zur sicherung
der grenzen und sie haben es eben schon
gesehen im zwischen schnitt wie wir das
nennen möchte bei den blick auf die
tribüne die sind nach wie vor wenn auch
nicht ganz so eng wie sonst besetzt doch
auf einer seite natürlich schon aber
besuchergruppen wird es ab kommenden
montag im deutschen bundestag wegen der
ausbreitung des corona virus nicht mehr
geben wie das dann in der nächsten
sitzungswoche auf den tribünen aussieht
auf den zuschauertribünen das wird das
parlament und insbesondere das präsidium
dann noch mal besprechen die kuppel
jedenfalls ist seit dienstag geschlossen
und ebenso die dachterrasse irgendwie in
beiden bereichen werden kommen ja schon
seit dienstag keine besucher mehr hinein
und derweil der bundestag der selber
durchaus zu tun hat mit dem virus das
sich verbreitet hat ein fdp abgeordneter
hat sich ja infiziert damit viele
mitarbeiter der spd-fraktion
beispielsweise müssen sich testen lassen
um eine weiterverbreitung auszuschließen
so gut es geht bekommt zurück in die
debatte der spricht josef oster für die
unionsfraktion das hätte ich in dieser
form den griechen gar nicht zugetraut
aber sie verdienen dafür unseren respekt
und unseren dank auch wenn die bilder
uns alle bewegt und teilweise sicherlich
auch erschrocken haben nur so war es
möglich dass präsident erdogan schnell
eingelenkt hat und meine damen und
herren zu dieser schnellen beruhigung
der lage hat ganz maßgeblich die
geschlossene haltung der europäischen
union beigetragen
daher gehen für mich von diesen wochen
drei zentrale botschaften aus die erste
lautet auf europa rollt eben keine neue
flüchtlingswelle zu und die grenzen sind
eben nicht offen
das hatte die afg zweifellos gerne
gesehen linke und grüne auch
zugegebenermaßen aus ganz anderen
beweggründen die zweite die zweite
zentrale botschaft europa hat sich nicht
von präsident erdogan erpressen lassen
eine wichtige botschaft dieser woche und
die dritte botschaft für mich europa
verschließt nicht die augen vor der not
der menschen und hilft aktuell
insbesondere den kindern das sind drei
ganz zentrale und bedeutsame botschaften
dieser phase verehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen die leidtragenden sind die
menschen die verzweifelt versuchen nach
europa zu gelangen und wer sind die
schuldigen für diese entwicklung ganz
bestimmt nicht die griechen ganz
bestimmt nicht die europäische union und
erst recht nicht deutschland
schuldig ist die perfide politik der
türkischen regierung die den zustrom die
wir gesehen haben von flüchtlingen und
migranten ganz gezielt organisiert hat
und ursächlich ist der krieg in syrien
das menschenverachtende handeln vor
allem von putin und erdogan für zu den
zuständen die wir jetzt in griechenland
erleben auch diese verantwortlichkeiten
gehören zu dieser debatte dazu und die
unsägliche rolle russlands blendet die
afg insbesondere ja sehr gerne auch aus
meine damen und herren liebe belege und
kollegen die letzten beiden wochen haben
gezeigt wie wichtig der konsequente
schutz der europäischen außengrenzen ist
nur wenn der schutz unserer außengrenzen
wirklich funktioniert können europäische
werte wie asylrecht und genfer
flüchtlingskonvention eine sinnvolle
anwendung finden
das thema migration davon bin ich
überzeugt wird mittel- und langfristig
die vielleicht größte herausforderung
für europa sein
daher ist eine starke und
handlungsfähige grenzschutzagentur
frontex von immenser bedeutung für die
zukunft der gesamten europäischen union
frontex muss stark werden durch mehr
personal und frontex muss handlungsfähig
werden durch mehr befugnissen deshalb
muss der europäische grenzschutz das ist
meine überzeugung bei der kommenden
finanzplanung der europäischen union
eine ganze herausgehobene rolle spielen
und dafür muss deutschland sich mit
nachdruck einsetzen
verehrte kolleginnen und kollegen die
beste grenzsicherung aber ist für mich
ein gemeinsames europäisches asylsystem
mit klaren regeln und schnellen
verfahren dann wird der druck illegaler
migration nachlassen und bilder wie die
der vergangenen wochen bleiben uns
hoffentlich erspart wenn asylsystem und
grenzschutz europäisch funktionieren
dann kann sich die eu auch wieder mehr
auf andere schwerpunkte konzentrieren
dazu gehört für mich eine noch stärkere
humanitäre hilfe in den krisengebieten
vor ort und dazu gehört für mich auch
eine viel aktivere außen und
sicherheitspolitik unser wichtigstes
ziel muss es doch sein humanitäre
katastrophen die jetzt in syrien gar
nicht erst entstehen zu lassen
vielen dank vielen dank
josef schuster war da ist so und dem vc
letzte redner in dieser debatte michael
kupfer aus der cdu/csu cdu csu fraktion
um genau zu sein da wollte ich
eigentlich in csu-mitglied damen und
herren von der afd
das halte ich für ihr haupt
geschäftsmodell nämlich der pflege von
empörung irgendwie blöd aber ich glaube
sie merken es selber dass es zur
empörung heute einfach kein anlass gibt
die richtige lösung kolleginnen und
kollegen besteht darin zwischen hilfe in
der not und illegaler migration sauber
zu trennen und dies möglichst an der eu
außengrenze zu klären
und genau das passiert aktuell
griechenland hat er bereits 37.000
illegale grenzübertritte verhindert die
juden minister haben die linie letzte
woche noch einmal sehr klar formuliert
ich zitiere illegale grenzübertritte
werden nicht toleriert
es werden alle nötigen maßnahmen
ergriffen um die eu grenzen zu schützen
wichtig ist auch dass wir uns innerhalb
der eu nicht mehr auseinanderdividieren
lassen
genau das passiert aktuell ebenfalls
deutschland handelt in enger abstimmung
mit den europäischen partnern und die eu
vertritt in dieser frage eine
geschlossene position und das führt ihre
kolleginnen und kollegen zu einem
weiteren wichtigen punkt der unser
aktuelles vorgehen kind zeichnet und ich
sage das ganz deutlich das schreiben wir
auch unserem rumpelstilzchen am bosporus
ins stammbuch
wir werden diesem versuch die eu und
deutschland zu erpressen nicht nachgeben
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
es ist weiterhin richtig griechenland in
einer gemeinsamen europäischen
anstrengung mit allen mitteln zu
unterstützen und auch hier zeigt sich
deutschland vorbildlich ich muss das
jetzt alles vor bieten sie kennen das 55
lkws mit hilfsgütern zelte betten des
thw mit einem großen einsatz
polizeibeamte aus bund und ländern
zollbeamte polizeiboote und
wahrscheinlich demnächst helikopter und
das liebe kolleginnen und kollegen von
den grünen zeigt vor allem auch eines es
ist keineswegs so dass die einzige
humanitäre lösung immer nur darin
besteht menschen nach deutschland zu
lassen oder so wie sie es am liebsten
hätten auch noch nach deutschland zu
holen
zum antrag der afg deshalb nur mit
einigen knappen worten
sie wollen dass wir der türkischen
regierung unmissverständlich klar machen
dass sie die grenzöffnung verurteilen
sie wollen dass die bundesregierung klar
macht dass ab sofort keine illegale
einwanderung über die bin über die
bundesgrenze mehr zugelassen wird
ja was soll ich dazu sagen
die bundeskanzlerin hat anfang der woche
sich klar geäußert
sie hat das verhalten der türkei als
inakzeptabel verurteilt sie hat den
außenministerien erdogan ausrichten
lassen dass er mit unserem widerstand
rechnen kann
die kanzlerin hat beim treffen mit dem
ministerpräsidenten mitsotakis nochmals
ausdrücklich den schutz der
aussengrenzen betonte der
regierungssprecher
hat am zweiten märz wortwörtlich gesagt
auch an die adresse potenzieller
migrantinnen und migranten in die welt
hinaus gesagt der weg in die eu ist
nicht offen
und jetzt wollen sie jetzt wollen sie
jetzt wollen sie das auch noch durch
erklärung der bundeskanzlerin klar
gemacht werden soll dass ab sofort keine
illegale einwanderung mehr zugelassen
wird dass ab sofort können sie streichen
illegale einwanderung wird nicht
zugelassen und da brauchen wir nicht nur
die erklärungen der bundesregierung
unter bundeskanzlerin die ich ihn
zitiert aber die hier keinen
interpretationsspielraum lassen sondern
noch deutlicher sprechen die ergriffenen
maßnahmen der letzten zwei jahre und
deren erfolge und damit sind auch ihre
restlichen fragen beantwortet wir haben
die bienen grenzkontrollen vorübergehend
wieder eingeführt und erhalten sie
seitdem aufrecht wir haben die
möglichkeit der zurückweisung im transit
verfahren eingeführt und wir werden auf
dieses instrument regulieren wenn sich
die notwendigkeit dazu bietet es genau
das was sie postulieren alles bereits
hergestellt wir haben im dezember
grenzkontrollen auf alle luft lang und
seegrenzen ausgeweitet auf dieser basis
in wenigen wochen bereits über 1000
zurückweisungen nebenbei auch noch
beifall
in dem personen festgenommen werden
konnten bei denen offene haftbefehle und
dergleichen vorlagen
wir haben eine reihe von effektiven
instrumenten eingeführt die sozusagen
als backup zum schutz der
eu-außengrenzen national greifen werde
und sie wissen vielleicht das eine sagen
die partei erst bayern dann nicht als um
maßgeblich beteiligt war wenn ich das
sagen da von der stelle
und ich möchte ganz zum schluss war ich
zum ende komme einem punkt nur
ansprechen denen sie in der ziffer 4 des
antrags nur andeuten
aber gott sei dank nicht aussprechen bei
den 1000 oder 1500 kindern bei dem sich
deutschland jetzt zusammen mit anderen
europäischen partnern bereit erklärt hat
sie aufzunehmen handelt es sich um
solche die entweder wegen einer schweren
erkrankung dringend behandlungsbedürftig
sind oder unbegleitet jünger als 14
jahre sind die meisten davon mädchen es
geht um 1000 kinder wir haben in
deutschland 11.000 gemeinden was das
bedeutet können sie sich ausrechnen und
deshalb sage ich ihnen einen satz zum
schluss die grenze muss hart sein und
das wird sie auch aber das herz nicht
meine damen und herren vielen dank
michael kupfer noch mal mit einem sprach
wird die grenze muss hart sein das herz
nicht es ging um die sicherung von
grenzen insbesondere um die türkisch
griechische grenze aber natürlich war in
dieser debatte auch immer wieder thema
die lage in den flüchtlingslagern auf
den griechischen inseln und michael
cooper hat auch eben angesprochen eine
formulierung in diesem antrag der afg um
den es hier ging und der jetzt
überwiesen werden würde in den
innenausschuss des deutschen bundestages
da wird man weiter drüber reden
dieser antrag enthält auch eine
in gewisser weise eine unterstellung
nämlich gesagt dass ab sofort keinerlei
versuche illegale einreisen über die
bundesgrenze mehr zuzulassen seien durch
die bundesregierung das würde ja heißen
dass diese illegalen einreisen
zugelassen würden und das ist nunmal
faktisch falsch heißt nicht dass es
vereinzelte fälle von illegaler einreise
gibt aber das heißt nicht dass die
bundesregierung sie zulässt also dieser
sachverhalt stimmt so nicht